so I love watching those movies like
those movies are special to me when I go
see like a Marvel movie like Brody
you know echoes my thoughts and should
hey man they're a triumph of cinema for
me they're not just fun because I grew
up with these characters and hey I can't
believe they're doing this now should
and I've lived long enough that I get to
see this [ __ ] up on the big screen it's
deeper than that man it's why I like you
know the people were going of all week
they were while we started the tour
they're like what do you think about
Martin Scorsese [ __ ] on Marvel
movies I'm like I'm not much I mean if
of course he does he's a [ __ ] master
storyteller he don't like action movies
he'd been saying that since the nineties
and [ __ ] and these movies are just
variations on an action theme and stuff
I said but he don't have the connecting
tissue to these movies like I think a
lot of people do if if somebody said hey
musicals aren't true cinema or whatever
Martin Scorsese would [ __ ] tell you
you're wrong and he would explain why
and it would reveal that like Martin
Scorsese grew up going to musicals with
his with his parents when he was a kid
like there's emotional connective
material there I grew up watching big
bombastic [ __ ] 80s action movies or
you know like war Raiders of Lost Ark or
Empire Strikes Back and stuff when I
step into one of those Marvel movies
it's the closest experience I have to
the experiences that I have when I was a
kid which means when I had all those
experiences as a kid my father was
sitting right next to me my father's
dead long dead he's been dead 15 years
at this point [ __ ] you can't bring back
the [ __ ] dead however when I watch
those Marvel movies that's the closest I
feel to my father it reminds me of
sitting there and watching those movies
with my dad I remember seeing Raiders of
the Lost Ark and him telling me the
whole time he's like they used to make
this movie when I was a kid like they
were cliffhangers and they were shorter
and so oh my god this is just like the
movie I used to watch when I was born
[ __ ] the magic of cinema washed over
him he wasn't a man of many words he was
no poet or anything like that but he
[ __ ] loved movies
he loved the escape of it all he worked
for the post office made
the [ __ ] out of that so he loved going
to the [ __ ] movies and [ __ ] so
because of that like the connective
tissue that I have emotionally when I
sit there watching movie not only Mike
[ __ ] these things are well plotted and
oh my god I can't believe [ __ ]
Falcons in this and [ __ ] like that then
I have the added [ __ ] layer and which
could be the cream in the [ __ ]
Twinkie as well which is oh my god for
two hours my father is alive again he's
sitting right there next to me we're
[ __ ] enjoying the [ __ ] out of this
together and then the credits roll and I
go back to reality so that's how a lot
of [ __ ] people feel not necessarily
like hey man I went to the movies with
my dad but there's an emotional
connection to this material it's not
just a theme park ride to them they're
invested deeply in these [ __ ]
characters and it doesn't matter whether
or not somebody says these characters
aren't shaded deep enough to care about
[ __ ] my only to each their own and
their own tastes and stuff but some
people won't ever have the connection to
those movies because they don't have
anything in their past that reminds them
of those movies that's what [ __ ]
fuels me other than them being well made
that's the only thing I've [ __ ] seen
on a screen in 25 years that takes me
back to before I was a filmmaker I know
how the [ __ ] sausage is made man like
so watching movies shouldn't wash over
me the same way at washers over people
generally I should be sitting there and
breaking [ __ ] down at a dollar a minute
going that looks expensive and blah blah
and [ __ ] like I know how that much
that [ __ ] costs and that
[ __ ] is a real piece of [ __ ] in
real life and stuff like that I should
be because that's my business that's
what I do but I can still get lost in a
movie theater man the only times in my
life I ever closest I ever came to
finding myself Who I am and [ __ ] was
never in a church it was never in a
[ __ ] school room it was in a goddamn
[ __ ] movie theater and stuff so movie
theaters my [ __ ] church man and like
you know the showing those Marvel movies
those are like High Holidays [ __ ] that's
like Christmas and [ __ ] that ain't
lint that's like Easter Sunday it [ __ ]
so him not getting over him not liking
it and I'm not saying he's [ __ ] dumb
he's not at all he's Martin Scorsese
he's brilliant but he doesn't have the
emotional connection to the [ __ ] so he
just looks at it is artifice where he's
like look at it it's just colorful noise
[ __ ] like that and he's absolutely
entitled to that opinion but I see magic
when I see those movies I see pure
alchemy I see somebody taking [ __ ]
cinema and turning it into I don't know
bringing my dad back it's [ __ ] raising
the goddamn dead as amazing stuff so for
me what was the original question
[Music]